how dope was it when because it uh was
it
the white house or joe biden's page or
somebody they actually did the whole
[ __ ] iron hell yeah joe byron
yeah renamed the president um it was him
well he didn't really say anything from
the thing he kind of it was the jonas
brothers right in the white house
and
at the end of the video you're just like
yo we got it it's him with the phone so
you know he was it was kind of his video
too right but uh i remember what i was
doing i think that might have been the
last day i ever packaged my own merch
because that's when it really was blown
up but every day something was happening
with the bing bong [ __ ] everybody every
day somebody knew was saying it well
this day was [ __ ] little nas x this
day is john legend singing hey y'all
take me out i'm like crazy which i still
got a sample by the way um
and every day was something new and new
and new and at that time the merch is
going crazy you know um so i'm packaging
my own [ __ ] i gotta hold my whole house
is full of mercy i gotta ship out i'm
like this is getting too crazy and i
remember shipping i had my man vanguard
with me helping me out and um
it's my dms like i stopped for a minute
i opened up my gram somebody did i'm
like oh
we made it like nah this is crazy the
president just said it crazy and uh
i mean you can't get more viral than
that what's um
like the latest on what's going on with
the joe byron guy
like the other he's out here in
california he's really i think he's in
like coachella valley where's palm
springs yeah it's like exactly coachella
that's near there so that's where he is
somebody sent me a video
of getting his [ __ ] together no doing
the same thing he was doing in [ __ ]
coney island
but [ __ ] i guess he made it across
country he's originally from california
oh so he just made it back to yeah this
is this i was looking through my videos
on instagram if you go back i don't know
on my lives not in my regular [ __ ] i
didn't post it on my like the grid but
there was one night i was i'm calling
and i just talked about like yo what how
the [ __ ] you want who are you why'd you
end up here i got his whole story and
he's originally from california and he
made it out there i don't know his
mother said you never make it to new
york some i don't know what the [ __ ]
it's all on my [ __ ] if you just you
gotta search though but uh he's somebody
sent me a video like yo
i'm the byron guy like two kids were
like yo names look we got this guy out
here i was like oh that's where it is
because i haven't seen them was it
wasn't there like a um was there like a
gofundme he made more money off that
video than any of us he made like 40
racks off of that good for him
absolutely i don't think he has any more
of it i think he spent it all
and he's back to square one at least
he's back in california at least he got
out here exactly at the very least he's
back home yeah yo we reunited him with
his son when the videos came out his son
dm me like yo that's my father [ __ ] and
i i asked him i was like yo you got a
son
he's like little tj he started [ __ ]
crying i was like yo look
he's just dm me he was like
so did he grasp how popping like that
video game oh yeah yeah because once
after a while we would be like yo
where's this guy we haven't seen him for
a minute he would just yeah he would
just pop up in times square and just be
like just yell out byron and crowds
would form around him
he was loving it he probably still loves
it remember that one dude uh
that got him got him
yeah yeah
that dude is is obviously he had him i
see him get scared on the train somebody
bullied him or some [ __ ] no bro he's
like
if you're if you go to vegas or i've
seen him on hollywood boulevard just
like he's like damn bad bro like he's
i'm pretty sure he's homeless or close
to it that's i seen a video recently
yeah
i've seen him like in person on
hollywood boulevard where i was like
that's melon
he already looked like something
beforehand but
like he um
there was a video he was on like a train
station and somebody was like yo he was
like he looks scared to death like yo
please don't hurt me the guy was like yo
i'm not trying to hurt you bro i just
want you to say it and he was like oh
okay got him yeah got him
[Laughter]
that's gotta be terrible